[Musique]
des incendies criminels sur plusieurs
tours de télécommunications au québec
ont récemment mis en relief une série de
théories qui établissent un lien entre
la technologie 5g et la pandémie de kobe
19 mai tous sortent ces théories au fait
mon collègue des fillettes a remonté le
fil du temps pour comprendre comment ces
idées ont fait leur chemin jusqu'à vos
écrans tout aurait commencé par une
obscure blog français liés aux
groupuscules le conspirationniste le 20
janvier de cette année un auteur anonyme
a publié un billet où il met en avant
l'hypothèse que la 5g aurait causé une
mutation du coronavirus deux jours plus
tard un journal belge publié une
entrevue avec un médecin local dans
notre vue le journaliste fait remarquer
que des taux 5 g ont été construites à
one le premier épicentre de la pandémie
puis demande aux médecins si ça peut
expliquer l'éclosion du nouveau
coronavirus je n'ai pas vérifié répond
le médecin qui poursuit en disant qu'il
se peut qu'il y ait un lien avec les
première éclosion kobe 19
le journal a eu beau retirer son article
il était trop tard rapidement les
groupuscules anti 5g belges se sont
emparés l'histoire de la satin d'autres
communautés semblables peu partout dans
le monde avant d'atterrir sur youtube où
elle a eu cette histoire une plus grande
visibilité
par la suite il ya des personnalités
plus connues des cercles
conspirationnistes comme le fondateur
d'un d'une foire alex jones ou encore
l'ancien footballeur britannique david
haye qu un inventeur la théorie voulant
que la terre soit secrètement contrôlés
par des reptiles y est ces deux là ont
relayé l'idée que la 5g cause l aco b19
alors vaste auditoire des vidéos youtube
et facebook
les mettant en vedette ont été vue des
millions de fois avant que youtube
décide de retirer ses vidéos là
jonathan morgane le pdg d'une entreprise
qui traque la propagation des
informations sur le web les réseaux
sociaux comme facebook youtube ou
twitter font en sorte que de petite
minorité de gens bruyants peuvent
manipuler la conversation pour lui le
principe est très simple un petit groupe
qui est extrêmement mobilisés par un
sujet en particulier par réussir à
dominer la conversation parce que ils
parlent plus que tout le monde est plus
fort que tout le monde voyait voyez ça
comme une chaîne alimentaire où il ya
toujours un poisson plus gros que toi
pour avaler ton histoire alors de forums
conspirationnistes obscur ça passe par
un bloggeur conspirationnistes puis ça
se retrouve sur rld et avant d'être
partagé sur twitter facebook et ça finit
par être relayée par des vedettes c'est
l'eau ça change aussi des vedettes comme
l'acteur américain woody harrelson où la
chanteuse mpc j'en est un sel qui a fait
d'un discours marginal un discours
davantage mainstream et la pandémie a
donc accélérer un processus qui aurait
normalement été pas mal plus long je
vous suggère fortement d'aller consulter
l'excellent texte de mon collègue gaja
fietz à ce sujet sur notre site web
n'oubliez pas d'adhérer à notre groupe
facebook et de regarder notre émission
diffusée sur ici amis tous les samedis
et dimanches
salut
[Musique]